If you're not saving your
user's game in the cloud,
I can guarantee you
are losing players
any time they get a new device.
Because no matter how awesome
your game is-- and I'm sure
it is-- nobody wants to start
all over again from level one
when they reinstall it.
I'm Todd Kerpelman, and while
there are many Cloud Save
solutions out there, the
one I'm here to talk to you
about today is the one you
get for free with Google Play
game services.
So the Play Games team has
upgraded their old Cloud Save
featuring in a major way.
Heck, it's such a big
update we have renamed
this feature from Cloud Save
to Saved Games-- in the cloud.
And we've got a fancy
new icon to go with it.
It's got an arrow in
it and everything.
But it doesn't just
have a new icon.
This new Saved Games
feature includes a bunch
of improvements over
the old Cloud Save.
The biggest of which is that
you can now save blobs of data
up to 3 meg large.
That is a lot of game data.
And while you were limited
to four slots earlier,
now you can have as
many as you want.
Your app will now have a Saved
Games badge in the Play Store
so everybody will
know that they can
save their progress
as they're playing.
You can also add metadata
to your saved game,
like a description
and a cover image.
All of which will
make your saved game
show up very nicely
in the Play Games app,
or within your own game.
I mean, look at that
beautiful saved game.
Don't you want to click on it?
I know I do.
You know, players see this
in the Play Games app.
They're reminded-- oh, yeah.
I was at this level.
I had just gotten
this cool new sword.
I'm going to keep playing
from where I left off.
So these features are great, but
along with these new features
comes a new way of
handling the saved game
data and new ways of
managing conflicts.
And I always find that when
dealing with this stuff--
particularly when it
comes to debugging-- it's
best to have a decent
understanding of how things
work under the hood instead
of it being some mystery
black box.
So let's take a peek
behind the scenes here.
You just might learn something.
So the first thing
you need to understand
is that Saved Games are
represented internally
as an object we call a snapshot.
The snapshot contains the
metadata, including things
like the description of a
file, a cover image, the amount
of time you've played,
and a local timestamp,
as well as the giant
blob of saved game data.
Saved Games are powered
by Google Drive,
and when you are
storing or loading
these Saved Games to
the Cloud, the best way
to picture what's going on is
that somewhere in the user's
Google Drive account,
there is a hidden folder
just for your application where
the snapshot is being stored.
And as these snapshots are
being saved inside the folder,
they're given a name
just like any other file.
And just like in a
normal file, these names
are the primary way we
identify these snapshots
to your application.
Your user, however,
never sees this name.
They'll see your snapshot's
description, cover image,
and maybe some other
metadata, but this name
is never surfaced to them.
It's really just an identifier
for your application to use.
Now you can query
and examine any
of the metadata
whenever you'd like.
But it's important to know
that to read the saved data,
or to write to it-- even if
you're writing to a brand
new snapshot-- you must
open the snapshot first.
Again, I guess it's kind
of analogous to accessing
local files in a
language like say Python.
You could find out the last
modified time of a file,
but if you want to
read or write to it,
you're going to need
to call open on it
to get the file handle.
Now most of this time,
this open command--
it's not very exciting.
What's happening
behind the scenes
is that your device is
downloading all this game
data associated with
your snapshot metadata
if it hasn't done so yet,
and then tells your game
when it's done.
But this command
does get complicated
when we handle
conflicts, so stay tuned.
Now with that in mind, let's
look at a simple situation
where we're going to load
an existing save game
from the Cloud,
make some changes,
and then save it again.
Loading or opening
a saved game starts
by opening up the snapshot
as identified by its name.
Now if you're only ever
dealing with a single save game
that you're going to
be saving and loading,
you could get away with
hard coding this file
name as a constant somewhere.
Remember, these saved games are
being saved in the user's drive
account in a folder
that is reserved just
for your application.
So you don't need to worry about
making these file names unique.
You don't have to call
it com.example.myap
p.savedGame.userId.
You could just call it
something as unoriginal
as like, SavedGame, or, I
don't know, Dan, I guess.
In Android Java land, loading
and opening a snapshot
is accomplished using the
Games.Snapshots.open method.
In the iOS world,
you're going to be
using the openWithFileName,
conflictPolicy,
completionHandler method.
And in the C++ world, you're
going to be using the snapshot
manager's open command.
The implementations
do vary slightly,
but you'll notice
in all cases, you
provide a name of the snapshot.
And by the end of
the process, you're
left with the snapshot
that has been opened
and is now available
for reading or writing.
Reading the contents
of a snapshot
is accomplished by
calling a second command
on the open snapshot, or
snapshot metadata object.
In Android land,
this is readFully.
In iOS, it's
readWithCompletionHandler.
And in C++, it's
read or readBlocking.
Again, this is a
separate command,
because while we can load the
snapshot data into memory right
away, we probably
don't want to have
to do this for a 3
meg chunk of game data
until we really have to.
And in all cases,
you're going to get back
a byte array, some
NSData, or a byte vector
that you can then pass
along to your game
and process as necessary.
Now let's say that we've
gone and opened your snapshot
and read in some data and
passed it along to our game.
And now the player
has made some progress
and wants to save their game.
To do this in
Android, you're going
to need to write
this game data back
onto the same snapshot
you opened earlier.
You're not going to
be creating a new one.
What you are going to do is
create a new snapshot metadata
change object.
So let's ignore the
rest of the snapshot
here and just look
at this new object.
The metadata change
object is basically
a list of elements
in the metadata,
such as a description,
time plate, or cover image,
that are different between
this version of the snapshot
and what was up there before.
Basically, the saved game API
will look at this change object
and kind of overlay it on
top of your old metadata
to create this new
metadata object.
Once you've done this,
you'll call commit and close
on Android devices
where you'll pass
in the old snapshot
with the new data,
and the metadata change
object right there.
On iOS and C++, it's slightly
different in that you do create
a new game data object instead
of writing over the old one,
but you're still creating a
metadata change object as well.
And then all that gets sent up.
You'll take the current
snapshot metadata
and call commitMethod on it.
You'll do something
similar in C++.
And in both cases, you can
see we have our currently
open snapshot, our
metadata change
object, and our new data.
Once you've saved
all this information
and committed your snapshot,
it is now considered closed.
And you'll want
to reopen it again
if you want to write
more data to it.
So easy peasy, right?
OK, so let's look
at some situations
where things can
get a little funky.
What do you do if this is a
brand new player, or somebody
who's never signed in
to game services before,
and they try to open a saved
game file that doesn't exist?
Actually, this isn't
really a problem.
On Android, one of the arguments
you pass to snapshots that open
is a createIfNotFound Boolean.
Set this to true,
and you're all set.
You simply open up a
snapshot with no data in it.
In iOS and C++, you don't
even need to do that.
It'll create an empty
file by default.
Then you simply treat
this empty snapshot
like any other snapshot.
It's just one that has no
data, and all of its metadata
is set to default values and/or
null, or I guess nil on iOS.
Simply by updating this
snapshot with your first set
of game data and a reasonable
metadata change object,
you can get this looking like
a real snapshot in no time.
So up until now, we've
talked as though you're just
loading and saving the same
game file over and over again.
But let's say you want to manage
more than one saved game file.
How do you do that?
Well for starters,
you're not going
to be hard coding
your snapshot name.
You're going to
need to figure out
which snapshot to save
and load at run time.
And to do that,
you're going to need
to give the player the ability
to pick which saved game they
want to use, create a
saved game, and so on.
Luckily, the UI
to handle all this
is provided for you by the
game services libraries.
When you want to present a user
with a list of saved games,
you can call up our UI.
Now there are several settings
you can tweak with this UI,
either as parameters
in Android and C++,
or as delegate methods
in Objective C.
These settings will let you
decide how many saved games
to show in this UI, whether
or not to give the user
the ability to delete a saved
game, and most importantly,
whether or not the user has the
ability to create a new save.
Now if I'm a user, and I click
one of these existing saves,
it'll hit a callback in your
game, and in that callback,
you'll get back the name
of the snapshot to open.
You can now just use this name
to open up the correct snapshot
just like before, and
you're ready to go.
But let's say I'm a user, and I
want to create a new save game.
I would click the
Save New Game button,
and your app then
gets a callback
that this button was clicked.
At this point, it's up to you to
basically create a new snapshot
by asking to open a saved
game with a name that does not
exist yet.
So how do you decide
what to name it?
It's kind of up to you.
You could use a timestamp--
that's pretty good.
You could use a
random number appended
to a timestamp-- I guess
that's even better.
You could query the names
of all the other snapshots,
examine them all,
and then increment
a number for the new one.
That'd work too.
The only trick is
that it needs to be
unique for this
particular player.
Doesn't need to be all
that memorable since,
as you just saw,
you're always going
to get that file name from the
UI that our library provides.
It will never be
surfaced to the user.
They're never going to need
to refer to it by name.
However you do it, as soon
as you request a snapshot
with a file name that
doesn't exist yet,
you get back an empty
snapshot that you can then
use as your new game.
Keep in mind that the
intended flow for all this
is like what you might
see at the beginning
of a console game.
I'm at the main menu,
I want to start a game,
and the game lets me pick from
continuing from a previously
saved slot or starting
a completely new game.
It's not really intended to
let the user switch saved
game slots mid-game or duplicate
their progress or anything
like that.
I mean, I suppose you could
hack it to work that way,
but it's going to
feel a little clunky.
OK, you've gotten this far.
Give yourself a pat on
the back because you
have completed level one!
OK, stop patting because
this is all good background,
but the real test
comes when you just
start detecting and
resolving snapshot conflicts.
And for that, you're
just going to need
to watch our next video.
Hopefully this link
will be live by the time
you're watching this, but
if not, check back soon
because it will be.
So thanks for watching, gang.
Feel free to follow
me on G+ or Twitter,
and I will see you
soon for part two.
Our exciting conclusion!
Dun-dun-dun.